National Police Association sues to make
trans Nashville school shooter Audrey
Hills Manifesto public days after Copp
said they were pausing plans to release
it due to pending litigation the
National Police Association filed the
suit on April 28 for the release of the
Audrey Hills penned Manifesto calls for
the release of Hale's manuscript has
have grown since hail opened fire on the
Covenant School in Nashville so here we
have a story about a transgender woman
who killed three children and faculty
members and we still don't know the
official reason but how funny is it that
a day after what happens in Texas
researchers funded by and supported by
intelligence agencies just happened to
have found an obscure Russian social
media profile that was posting to no one
with no followers yes sorry I I I'm just
I'm not going to buy it but you know
like if regular people want to believe
this stuff I don't care it's true it's
not like it was his Facebook page it's
not like it was his Twitter account it's
not like he had some YouTube page with a
ton of stuff on it I think that I read
that there is a YouTube page but it
wasn't it wasn't extensive so the whole
idea that that there's this this long
history of him watching these things and
blah blah these are very very uh
superficial and only surface level
connections and they're doing everything
they can to make it you know about about
it's the spaghetti technique exactly yes
you throw it against the wall you see
what sticks and none of this is going to
stick this week and he said it's not
backstop it's not shorts what's
interesting too is look National Police
Association is the one suing for it and
I don't claim to speak for all law
enforcement but I know enough people
that work in the law enforcement world
that's the background that I came out of
and I've got buddies who are former cops
I got buddies that are former federal
agents they all want this thing public
there's no excuse for not exposing it
and and so generally speaking people and
that's that's the nice thing about the
story is that you see there is someone
from the National Police Association
putting money behind a lawsuit saying
we're trying to get this thing out I
guarantee you the people that work for
Nashville PD want it out too they want
to because their officers responded in a
Flawless way technically yeah like
outstanding response to what happened
right they went out there and they
solved the problem in a way and when you
look at those guys like they were not
they were not gung-ho about being that
that wasn't the day they planned the guy
even gave his press conference I thought
it was really emotional but they want
this thing out too because they want to
say look this is evil in the world we're
calling it out that's what you sign up
this is this is a good example of the
big problem of our attention spans in
society in that when the cops do a bad
job they get all the attention in the
world when it comes to Uvaldi their
story story non-stop questions why did
this happen how did this happen and uh
we don't give enough attention or
gratitude to the officers who do the job
right as tragic as it is but they rush
in you I mean that body camera footage
of what happened it's it's it's it's
it's crazy it's going to be taught in
tactical uh so the the actual techniques
are called alert that's the training
that people go through it's a law
enforcement standard across the country
it comes out of the Texas State
University in San Marcos put out this
thing after Columbine because they said
we got to standardize the idea that
we're going to have the cops going into
these scenarios and they're going to do
it the right way so they wrote the book
on it I have the book actually in my
garage and they teach it at multiple
different levels these guys executed a
master class in that because you never
know all the information they got keys
to the doors that's a huge just a heads
up move they rolled in they uh they had
comms they had one guy that was driving
everything they had another guy that was
doing you know you know people get tax
saturated they go into a room and they
just all they can pay attention to is
staying alive because there's a
potential shooter behind every door and
they went right to that threat as soon
as they heard something they changed
tactics I mean these guys crushed it and
they should be the focus there should be
they should be at the White House you
know honestly yes absolutely losers show
up at the White House and get medals for
you know Medals of Freedom these guys
did the thing they I I did a whole show
on this called the Super Bowl of
masculinity but it's essentially like
imagine you woke up in the morning you
put on your pants like you normally do
you went and you started your car you
had your coffee you went to go do your
thing and suddenly it's like today's
your day to be a man at the highest
level that you can be a man you're going
to save children and put your life on
the line right now and no one's giving
you any warning you're getting tapped
from nowhere to step into the Super Bowl
and throw a touchdown pass and those
guys completed the pass and they crushed
it and they and everyone now knows you
will get no you'll get limited gratitude
that's right limited they they won't
give you a week of air time like they
give the bad cops you will not be
invited to the White House no book deal
no book deal well I mean look it's human
nature right uh good things just happen
bad things are somebody's fault
hmm
that's intense yeah yeah that's really
sobering and honestly it's really sad
too because that is there there was a
time when we did celebrate Heroes that
did heroic things this country used to
understand that and now it's about the
the media cycle which generates clicks
and it likes and it's got to be rage
based not only it is I think there's a
good there's an argument to be made that
on the left there was more celebration
of the shooter than there was of the
police officers who went in there and
took them out so you saw those left-wing
protesters going there were seven
victims here unbelievably insane and
then you also had the media going out
and engaging in not only apologetics
for the left-wing narrative but
essentially for the act of violence that
took place if it was motivated by
left-wing ideology imagine right imagine
we had nailed down conclusive proof that
the reason that this Maniac committed
this recent shooting was because he was
a white supremacist and he did this
because he believed there was a white
genocide etc etc imagine if when the
media was talking about it they followed
up the story of the event with but white
people are having their rights taken
away and there is an effort to import
other people to replace they claimed he
was a victim and this shooter was a
victim but that is literally exactly
what happened I know I know and so it
makes it even more insane but that is
literally exactly what happened when
this trans person shot a bunch of
children all the stories were now we
should remind you that trans rights are
under threatened this country though
there is really a trans genocide etc etc
etc well on that last point I think
there is you know well the left because
the left is sterilizing that right with
Lance you know we talked about the left
Lexus is a trans genocide and I'm like
well I agree I think it's when you
sterilize trans people is prevent them
from reproducing um that's not I
seriously think so I mean it's
terrifying well yeah I would prefer it
if they would stop but it's right out of
Rules for Radicals though right accuse
your opponent of what you're doing they
accuse us of being genocidal for saying
don't sterilize kids
and people believe it it's ridiculous
well so will we get do you guys think
we'll get the manifesto the police have
already intimated this was I think that
said it was politically motivated
motivated by resentment and the rumors
I've heard from uh various sources is
that it it seems to explicitly reference
conservatives trying to restrict child
sex change surgery
I've heard the same and and I I will say
whether this comes out or not could be
dependent on whether there are people in
the intelligence agencies who are
willing to blow the whistle like you did
yes and if if it's actually first of all
somebody read this that was picking up
this was going to be a Frontline cop
this is somebody who's conducting the
search warrant at the house that was
conducting the search of the premises
that booked it into evidence this thing
had some eyes on it right that's why
we're getting some of the information
we're getting so some of those people
they you know they the sad thing is this
our country used to celebrate a look
behind the curtain a look into sort of
like what the government is up to when
they're keeping it from us that's what
the New York the New York Times used to
do that sort of thing classified
documents being leaked that was a
celebration on behalf of the media
because they said we're going to hold
the powerful to account and journalism
used to be a blue-collar Endeavor and
now what we see is they defend whatever
that narrative is on the behalf of the
government we were talking before we
started but it's like when did the kids
stop being so punk rock yeah like the
whole game used to be that whatever the
man wants I'm going to do the opposite
even if it's dumb for me the kids are
not doing that the band The Offspring
has a song on their first album that I
cannot say the name of
if I say the name of one of the songs on
their first album and anybody can Google
it it would likely result in some
attitudes knocking on my door the next
day let me just put it that way they the
name of the song is a direct threat on
government officials telling instructing
people to do a thing and they had that
song available I think for like 10 or 12
years until I had it on cassette the
song I'm pretty sure yeah you probably
did I had the first album on cassette
and then you definitely did and uh this
was punk rock and then they got famous
and Rich and now their uh guitar player
has me blocked on Twitter talk about
like just crazy even the idea it's it's
not Punk it's not punk you know well I
think Gavin McGinnis said it he said the
most punk rock thing in the world you
could do right now is like marry
somebody of the opposite sex and then go
make some babies and take them to church
and raise you know human beings that pay
taxes like that's punk rock right it's
funny that's what my wife and I are
doing it's the funniest thing you can
imagine but you look over and there's
there's memes too where they say like
what you thought the resistance and the
rebellion was going to look like what it
actually looks like right and what you
thought it looked like was like people
burning stuff in the streets and having
the zombie apocalypse you know fight
back and what it looks like is like
people homesteading and growing a garden
you know having having their own animals
like you guys do here so a lot of that
is you know the resistance is not what
people think it is but uh but that's
because kids stop being punk rock they
stop looking to resist whatever the
mainstream is and we're talking about
Bootleggers it's the same thing it's
like apparently that's a virtue now well
it's also funny because like 99 of the
people who will call you a boot licker
like want higher taxes and to live in a
pod and eat bugs Cover Me Harder right
yeah exactly you know it's it's
remarkable how quickly it changes even
up until 2021 the idea of Revolution or
Revolt or Insurrection were celebrated I
remember during the George Floyd BLM
riots there were left Wingers posting
online hey conservatives who claim you
care about the Second Amendment now
would be a good time to rise up against
the government since they're violating
our human rights and then January comes
around oh my goodness we're in a country
full of insurrectionists how could the
right wing tread and of course we all
know j6 wasn't an Insurrection it's all
nonsense but the point still stands
because they labeled an Insurrection now
Insurrection is a No-No but they were
they were literally fans of it when
people were burning down cities when the
White House was surrounded and the
barricades were broken down and they
forced the government and the president
Into the Bunker and the gravel Institute
tweeted that they thought it was good
that it happened but it was just the
wrong people Mark Hughes yeah it's all
Herbert it's all standard leftist
tactics we talk about this stuff all the
time and we I mean but they're not
changing their minds no they're not and
they're not gonna change it
I think
so here's the thing I I was in Portland
when they had the riots I did an
undercover surveillance Mission there
for about about two weeks uh which was
interesting and spicy there were things
that were pretty Rowdy I watched a
7-Eleven get taken over that was really
weird there were dudes on the top of the
7-Eleven across from the Portland Police
bureau's Union Hall which is like their
you know wherever their Union meets and
they were throwing Fireworks off there
you know explosive devices that could
have done real damage and at the same
time I was also outside of Lafayette
Square the day after they burned it and
they burned St John's Church we were
standing there Toe to Toe with Secret
Service guys who had caught bricks in
the head and nobody seemed to be upset
about it and then the other crazy thing
that you'd see was these like and it's
always these lib leftist women which are
ubiquitous and UDC they they were
bringing snacks for the protesters so
they're bringing like bags of granola
bars and stuff to fuel the rioters later
on that night and they're putting them
on top of piles of bricks and I'm like
one why are there loose bricks here on
the street this seems like a security
problem we're gonna solve that also what
are you trying to do because I guarantee
if you had done something like that for
January 6th let's say you were running
like a you know know Riot ribs outside
of the January 6 uh you know the protest
you would be hit with like some sort of
like providing material support to
terrorism I guarantee it it would have a
266 case on you from the FBI and they'd
be banging on your door to take your rib
you know your rib uh smoker yeah and
most of the people who got your ribs are
probably been feds too
this is for feeding government workers
without a permit
[Laughter]
it's infuriating but at the same time
getting upset and and sitting there
complaining about the hypocrisy is
absolutely counterproductive to it's
really a better position to just expect
it and try to anticipate what their
stories are going to be and just go
about your day and and make sure that
you have you know some kind of some kind
of uh response but for the most part
it's just like look you're they're gonna
say that stuff and you have to continue
going about your your day and doing what
you're doing because they're gonna call
you names they're gonna try and lay
everything on you that's the leftist
tactic is blame the other person for the
things that they're doing you know do as
much as they can to discredit you in
front of other people so that way people
they throw them out without like they
don't care if there's any background to
it I got a letter from the FBI in
February stating that I was racist
sexist and or with a slash homophobic
during the six weeks I was in the office
when I didn't talk to anybody in uh in
May and April is that right no March and
April of last year and I didn't talk to
anybody I sat there and I'm like and or
like which one of these was I is there
is there any story is there any
background is there substance and this
is a legitimate you know government
agency semi-legitimate at least uh
nominally a constitutional group that
theoretically would have to put some
information behind it they put that out
there and so I shared it on Twitter
because I don't care like I just think
it's funny so I and people go hey you're
really slacking off you could have been
transphobic and xenophobic and you
missed the boat and it's like ah I
obviously yeah if you didn't get enough
of these if you're not getting enough
insults lobbed your way you're not
actually doing the job thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time